[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the opening lecture
of the series myths about america
this lecture series
has been organized by mit's special
program for urban and regional studies
in short spurs
a spurs is institutionally located
in the department of urban studies and
planning at mit
i'm bish sanyal director of spurs
and it is an honor for me
to welcome professor howard zinn
the speaker this
evening i also want to welcome
all of you
the fellows
the students faculty and staff
perhaps there are others in the audience
who do not fit any of these categories
but are eager nonetheless to participate
in our deliberations on myths about
america i welcome to you all
let me provide a very brief description
of spurs
the program which is hosting this
lecture series
for some of you who may not know
spurs was created in 1967
a critical historical moment much like
the time we are living now
and it was created for mid-career
professionals
from around the world who wanted to
spend a year at mit
reflecting on their work experience
in a setting
very different from their work
environment
and one which provided opportunities for
reflection and learning
now a majority of the fellows in the
program are supported by the fulbright
exchange program
for practitioners
named after the late senator hubert
humphrey
one key objective of this program
is to cultivate international
understanding of the us
by other nations in asia africa latin
america and the middle east
as you well know
the need for such an understanding is
more important now than ever before
the selection of the theme
and the speakers for this year's lecture
series
was made with this particular objective
in mind
we assumed that most international
fellows and students
come to the u s
with certain preconceived opinions and
perceptions
regarding american society politics and
economy
the goal of this lecture series
is to subject such prescription such
perceptions to critical scrutiny
drawing on historical evidence
we hope that such scrutiny of both
negative and positive myths about
america as held by others
and also by americans themselves
will help the fellows better understand
this nation
a few individuals and institutions
deserve thanks
for the organization of this lecture
series
first the department of urban studies
and planning at mit which is currently
headed by professor larry vale who i see
is in the audience
api what ratnawara
nimva de leon
and jenny pakarduni without whose help
we could not have organized this lecture
series and finally i want to thank the
fellows themselves
for their intellectual curiosity
and eagerness to better understand the
us
we are honored that this process of
critical understanding is to be started
with a lecture by professor howard zinn
who does not need much of an
introduction
a people's history of the united states
which professor zinn published in 1980
is a book that has inspired many
who could for the first time
see their own contributions to the
nation's historical evolution
thanks to this new history from below
but howard zinn
is not a person
whose experience
is confined to non-traditional social
groups at the bottom of american society
he's a decorated war veteran who flew
bombing missions in europe during world
war ii
returned from the war
and attended new york university on the
gi bill
and then went on to attend columbia
university where he earned a master's
degree and a phd in political science
later he became the chair of history and
social science at spelman college in
atlanta a college for black women where
he became deeply involved in civil
rights movements
howard zinn's understanding of the us
is based as much on such concrete first
first-hand experience
as on academic studies of historical
events
the combination of these two sources of
knowledge has cultivated a mind which is
at once sharply analytical deeply
empathetic and patriotic too in a way in
which is necessary for our times
so with much admiration i present to you
the opening speaker of our lecture
series professor howard zinn who will
speak this evening
on the topic of the myth of american
exceptionalism
professor zin will speak for an hour
at or 45 minutes to an hour at the end
of which he will have an exchange of
views with you thank you
[Applause]
no
thank you
professor sanyal for a nice introduction
can you all hear me
and and also for inviting me
not everybody invites me
and uh sometimes i have to go places
uninvited
but uh it's good to good to be here at
mit
and uh
are any of you back there having trouble
hearing me
no
one person
oh okay
american exceptionalism
the myth of american exceptionalism
and
by the way
when
i told a friend of mine
that i was
going to give a talk on american
exceptionalism
she immediately
got in touch with a
somebody who had been a student of hers
and i think who is now teaching
and
who sent me a paper on american
exceptionalism
but i will not read her paper
although she has some interesting good
you know and useful
uh useful things to say
and uh
i'm
and one of the points she makes is
that by american exceptionalism we don't
mean that the united states is
simply unique simply different all
countries are unique all countries are
different it it's exceptionalism
suggests more than that
it suggests superiority
it suggests
something that
all of us living in the united states
have encountered a lot
and that is
self-congratulation
that we are a fund in the united states
of congratulating ourselves for how
wonderful we are
and uh
how we are the best we are the greatest
we are the strongest we are the most
prosperous
we are the freest
we are the most democratic
and
yes
we are number one
and we are in fact number one in many
things and we are very good
really very good in many things and
those are the things i probably don't
have to tell you about because
anybody who is in the united states
anybody even for a short time you know
knows because the things that that the
united states is good about are
immediately apparent
uh
but
that's not enough
uh that doesn't tell the whole story
and if if we only dwell on what we all
acknowledge are some of the remarkable
things about the united states we will
be missing something very important
something in fact so important
that
we'll be shocked
if something happens one day
that
arouses us
from our complacency
and that
makes us wonder how it is that a country
so
s
gifted
so special so superior
should experience
suddenly a disaster that nobody can
explain
you know and
well yes when
9 11 happened
that was an occasion perhaps for
reflection on ourselves a sober and
critical reflection on ourselves
that did not happen in the higher
reaches of government
the the people at the top of the
government are not given to
self-reflection or to self-criticism
uh no
instead you know the reaction was a a
kind of a hysterical reaction
reaching out
or reaching as an euphemism
war
violence attack
do something
but no
no reflection
uh
so i think that that kind of
examination
of who we are
as a country
is needed so we
won't be unguarded so we won't be
shocked when something terrible happens
so we will perhaps begin to understand
i mean this idea of self-congratulations
sometimes
manifests itself this way that that
if you criticize
the united states government
uh
and
a lot of people here probably
experienced this as anybody who has
ever uttered a word of criticism
you're met
with the
uh
exhortation
um
well why don't you
go somewhere else
well sometimes i say why don't you go
back to where you came from you know
which might be brooklyn
you see but but it's it's
some but somehow go somewhere else
a friend of mine who is
a comedian
i mean i have friends of mine who are
comedians but who don't know it
but this is a guy who is a comedian and
who knows it
uh but he's also serious
um some of you have maybe even
encountered him because he used to do
comedy here in the boston area his name
is barry crimmons and and and when and
in his serious comedy he would
very often be critical of certain things
uh that the united states had done in
the world you know and and people would
say well why don't you move somewhere
else and he would say i don't want to
move somewhere else because i don't want
to become the victim of american foreign
policy
well this this notion of
superiority and exceptionalism starts
early
and
sarah merton who wrote this book points
out that it starts as early as
you know well here in
massachusetts bay colony in 1630 the
colony had just begun and and the
governor
winthrop
uh utters those words which
centuries later will be repeated
by ronald reagan who is a great student
as you know of early american history
and
the
winthrop
talked about
the massachusetts bay colony
as
a city on a hill
i think reagan embellished it a little
and talked about a golden city on a hill
well the idea of a city on a hill
you probably heard that expression a
number of times the idea of a city on a
hill uh is a is a nice one
because it suggests
a model
that suggests setting an example
it uh
actually it's it suggests what in fact
that george bush has spoken of and he
said you know we uh
we are a beacon of liberty and democracy
and if if
if that was what we were if that's all
we are if that's we're a city on a hill
that people can look to and people can
learn from people can admire and people
can emulate
i mean that is a wonderful thing to be
but it doesn't stop there with just
being a city
on a hill
in fact you can see it because of just a
few years
after
uh governor winthrop utters these words
about being a city on a hill just a few
years later
the
people in the city on a hill
move out to
massacre
the peacock indians
who
seem to think they belong
on this land
and uh
there's a description of that
uh
which was uh
william bradford was one of the early
settlers in massachusetts at that time a
contemporary of winthrop wrote a history
of the plymouth plantation and and he
talks about how you know the captain
mason uh
attacking a peacock village
said you know
we must
burn them
and
and then
bradford reports those that escaped the
fire were slain with a sword some hued
to pieces some
uh
run through with their rappers so as
they were quickly dispatched and very
few escaped it is conceived that thus
destroyed about 400 at this time it was
a fearful sight to see them frying in
the fire and the streams of blood
quenching the same
but the victory seemed a sweet sacrifice
and they gave prayers thereof to god
who had wrought so wonderfully for them
and given them so speedy a victory
over so proud and insulting an enemy
and
very early on
there's an association
between what the government does
and what god approves of
uh
and
in
that process of not being just a city on
the hill but of moving out
of expanding
continued
that's a
persistent fact of american history
going all the way back
to those first settlers and coming down
to the present day the persistence of
expansion into somebody else's territory
and occupying that territory and dealing
harshly with with the people
you know who resist that occupation
and uh
you know one of the things that when you
study the american revolution school one
of the things they don't tell you uh uh
although we know about the good things
with the american revolution
independence from england and the
declaration of independence and all of
that
but
generally they they skip over the fact
that independence from england uh for
the colonists
was disastrous for the indians
because it meant that from now on the
colonists who had been restrained by the
british in their proclamation of 1763
setting up a line a boundary uh within
which the settlers were supposed to stay
so as not to encroach into indian
territory this uh boundary line was now
uh erased and now the colonists now with
the revolution victorious with
independence from england the congress
could move westward you know into indian
territory
because that process you know continued
on and on
with the kind of
description that you heard of the
peacock massacre occurring again and
again in american history as we moved
across
uh to the west coast and down uh you
know to the
gulf of mexico and this notion of god
being involved
this notion of being
sort of divinely ordained now that that
notion continued in the
middle
of the 19th century
on the eve of the war with mexico when
the united states had just annexed texas
a lot of americans don't know that texas
was just part of mexico
a lot a lot of people in the united
states don't know that california was
once part of mexico they wonder why do
they have all these spanish names out
there
sand this and santa this and say yeah
well
but on the eve of war with mexico
this
famous phrase was coined by a a writer
and editor named
john o'sullivan he spoke about
manifest destiny
and
he
he said it was our manifest destiny
to overspread the continent
allotted by providence for the free
development of our yearly multiplying
millions
providence god
continued to be involved in expansion
when
when the united states
went into the philippines
at in the beginning of the 20th century
president mckinley
some of you may know this because it's
uh not everything that i say to people
is an obscure fact and sometimes i tell
people that they really know
maybe often i tell people things that
they really know sometimes i think
everything i tell people is something
they really know but i say it anyway
and
but you may have heard that mckinley
said that the decision to invade the
philippines
came
you know one night you know
when he
prayed
and god
uh told him to take the philippines
and so
this is a
very
dangerous kind of idea once once you
have god's
permission to do what you want you you
need
no
uh criterion of of
human morality
and
and with
president bush
if you don't mind me skipping
immediately
a lot of american history to
a president bush
uh
i mean it's well known that bush has a
special relationship to god
uh
and and that bush invokes god every
chance he gets he's not the only
president you know i mustn't be too hard
he's not the only president who does
this the invoking god is a very common
thing all you know through american
history but bush has made a
specialty of it
and
he
now i'm going to tell you something
where i don't know if this is true
not all historians
will admit that the things they tell you
may not be true
but
it sounds true to me
how's that for scientific
a bit of evidence
uh
and that is uh an article appeared in
the in the israeli newspaper har rats
any of you
remember an article that appeared
in the israeli newspaper rs
in which the reporter talks about
talking to palestinian leaders who had
met with bush
okay
finally i'm telling you something that
is
not only fairly new but dubious
but
uh
but according to this reporter he spoke
to his palestinian leader and
palestinian leader reported on his
conversation with bush and as he
reported bush told him
god told me to strike at al qaeda
and i struck them
and then he instructed me to strike at
saddam
which i did
and now i am determined to solve the
problem in the middle east
well as i say who knows
you know it's one of the situations we
get something second and third hand it's
just that it's plausible
knowing bush
it's uh whether it's true or not
it's plausible it fits everything else
this this uh this now i'll give you a
piece of evidence which is
i think
more credible
uh that is it's it's closer to home
here's because here's the this is the
president of the
um
ethics and religious commission of the
southern baptist convention
friend of bush
and says that bush told him during the
election campaign quote
i believe god wants me to be president
now
i would consider that
interference
in a free election
i mean
and
god wants me to be president
now this actually was reported in the
newspaper
and and uh and the
uh
and and this man richard lamb who
says that bush told him this during the
election campaign
he resented the fact that it was quoted
i believe god wants me to be president
but it was quoted out of context
context was that bush followed this up
by saying but if that doesn't happen
it's okay
well i i thought
yeah
that's reasonable
uh he's
you know
willing
willing to change his mind if god
changes
his or her mind okay
um
this
this idea of god
uh giving
strength to whatever the government does
you know is something that is true you
know not just with bush but at the
higher reaches of american government
uh with people around bush
and
and justice scalia
justice scalia i don't know how closely
you watch him
but
oh this is an aside because i just got
this in the mail today and that was uh
something uh publication
of the dramatists guild in which they
haven't
uh they reproduce a talk that the
playwright tony kushner gave at bard
college and it's all about scalia
but that's just
an aside scalia
seriously believes that god is the
source of governmental power
and he has said this again and again
and uh
he's uh
he's spoken
uh
well
two years ago at the union university of
chicago divinity school said government
is the minister of god
government derives its moral authority
from god
and uh
i mean this is a
dangerous idea
in anybody's hands
uh scalia seems to be overlooking the
fact that the declaration of
independence suggests
that
government gets its power
his authority
excuse me from the people
i mean that's what the
government gets its authority from the
people it's answerable to the people if
the government
doesn't
make sure that people have an equal
right to life liberty and pursuit of
happiness it is then the people who have
the right
to as the declaration of independence
says to alter or abolish the government
but
i suppose scalia is a strict
constitutionalist
and the declaration of independence is
not part of the constitution in fact the
declaration of pence is not a legal
document at all
it's just
you know
the most idealistic statement that could
come out of the american revolution
and want to be put aside as soon as you
win the revolution
uh
so this idea of
of
god being the source of governmental
power
i mean it's always dangerous in
anybody's hands i mean it's dangerous
when people
call themselves the chosen people
it's dangerous there too
uh
but if these people don't have a lot of
power there's not much they can do with
that they can sort of enjoy the fact
that they are the chosen people
if there's some point in history where
they
develop the power to
do something to somebody else
uh well then then it becomes serious and
we've seen then there are uh
people who
in israel who
have uh
uh
who justify the
uh
the occupation of the west bank on
sort of very pragmatic grounds of
security and self-defense but there are
others
there are
religious fanatics who justify the
occupation
on the basis of yes being the chosen
people and being
chosen by god to do this
uh
of course there are
there are
there are important people important
jews who have
uh opposed this idea of calling
themselves the chosen people
considering uh
what terrible things have been done in
the name of
of
being selected by god
um after all the
the nazi storm troopers had on their
belts
gut mit on scott with us
so it's a dangerous concept when
especially when
people who believe they are instructed
by god have great military power and the
nazis with their military power and with
that kind of
divine ordination
we know what they did
did uh in europe and now you have the
united states
and you have a government
which
assures us
gets its
power from
god and with the in the hands of the
united states this is a dangerous
doctrine because of simply because of
the great power
of the united states
to do whatever they think is god's will
that is a a
nation with
10 000 nuclear weapons
a nation with
military bases and a hundred different
countries which warships on every sea
when you couple that power with the
notion of divine sanction uh then then
the world you know is
uh
in danger
and
this idea
you see
that
the united states
should use its power in the world
should revel in this being number one
that they became especially
important at the end of world war ii
because at the end of world war ii the
united states did become
the preeminent power in the world yes
there was a soviet soviet union uh but
but it was the united states that was
you know the greatest
economic and and with the
atomic weapons greatest
military power
in the world and at the end of world war
two
uh henry luce who is one of the
i guess most important
non-governmental people one of the most
powerful non-governmental people in the
country you know the
owner of a vast chain
of media enterprises the
man who owned time
life
and fortune
i mean not just the magazines but the
things themselves
uh but henry loose said
that this uh
this would be
the american century
uh
as he put it uh
the
victory now at the end of world war ii
gave the united states the right to
exert upon the world
the full impact of our influence
for such purposes as we see fit
and by such means
as we see fit
and that idea
that we do what we want
that this is the american century that
in fact
persisted
and was acted out through the rest of
the 20th century
uh because the united states you know
continued to expand even even with the
soviet union
there
and and soon acquiring its own nuclear
weapons
the the
united states continue to expand into
its influence in well
into the oil regions of the middle east
by this special arrangement with saudi
arabia
uh
into
asia uh with japan
and
and
into certainly into latin america
and
you know there were some setbacks
you know setback in
in vietnam
and but the philippines remained
a very important base for the united
states
and yes and soon the united states had
military bases all over the world and
soldiers and sailors stationed all over
the world
and
the uh
and the cold war with the soviet union
did not
really do much to
stop this expansion in fact the cold war
the existence of the soviet union as a
rival the existence of something called
a communist threat in the world
gave
the united states a justification
for doing so much of what it was doing
in the world for
expanding its power in the world for
overthrowing this government or that of
government or moving troops here and
moving troops there and all
justified by the necessity of stopping
communism
now you
you can see
that
i think
historically
that this was a
an artificial justification
by that i mean
that
that this wasn't the real reason for
american expansion in the world the real
reason for american special was not
to stop communism after all
that expansion was a continuation of
expansion which had gone on for a long
time
if you want to see the uh the limits of
that idea that that it was the soviet
union in a cold war which was the reason
for america united states expanding its
power in the world all you have to do is
is ask the question
uh what was going on before 1917.
what was going on before there was a
bolshevik revolution you mean at that
point the united states was just
mind-minding its own business
uh no
uh
long before and long before the
bolshevik revolution
the united states was engaged in
expanding its power into the caribbean
uh into the pacific
so uh
what happened of course is that the cold
war ended
that justification ended
but very soon after
9 11 happened
and once 9 11 took place
another justification appeared
terrorism replaced communism
as a kind of
simple answer to the question of you
know why are we going here why are we
going there why are we making war here
why are we sending troops there
and you know in in the in the 50s you
know why we overthrowing the government
of guatemala the government of chile or
the government of iran well it's
communism
and now
and now it's terrorism
and it has a certain plausibility
because there was a reality to communism
but what we did in relation that reality
went far beyond
what the real threat was there's a
reality to terrorism but what we do in
relation to terrorism
does not quite meet the requirement
of
uh
having an effect serious effect on
terrorism
and it does suggest
uh that there are
motives
deeper
than
the idea of
fighting terrorism for the american move
into the middle east in these past few
years
so
one year after the after 9 11
president bush announces you know the
national
security strategy
um and this basically lays out the
principles for american
foreign policy
and
lays out the principles of
unilateralism
the and the
preemption
and
making sure that
no power
can rival
the
power of the united states in the world
and
essentially this is a declaration that
the united states could ignore
the u.n charter because if you if you if
you accept preemption
then you are violating the principle of
the u.n charter that you're only
supposed to make war in
self-defense
uh
and uh
and i suggest to you also violating the
principles laid down in in the nuremberg
trials
for which the nazi leaders were put on
trial and and hanged and that is
for
uh aggressive war
or pre-emptive war
that that wore not in self-defense
so this is a very serious thing
this declaration
of
principles
in the national security strategy
and
we shouldn't think it was just
a bush
republican
uh
idea
you know it's apparently we like to
think
that
before bush things were okay
and
and that bush represents a dramatic
departure
from whatever we had before
but in fact
preemption is something that
after all the united states
has made war before and invaded
countries before well as we did in
southeast asia which was certainly not a
matter of defending ourselves
you know
and the united states has done as the
made war unilaterally this and this
before bush made war unilaterally or
carried out bombing missions uh
unilaterally
i mean sometimes creating a kind of
cloak of
uh of internationalism by bringing in
nato or some or by bringing in the u.n
uh as as in korea but basically an
american
enterprise
and in fact
under clinton madeleine albright
said at one point some of you may
remember that she said you know we will
if
if
possible we will act
in the world
multilaterally
but if necessary
we will act unilaterally
so
yeah
and
you know clinton was
not you know averse to acting
uh unilaterally
and preemptively
and uh
what happens
in a present situation
is that
i must say this
that very often
liberals in the united states
people who are not for bush
yes liberals uh in the united states
uh
accept
with sort of
qualifications here and there but except
basically the
the bush principles
and
[Music]
the reason for this i think is
that 9 11
had a very powerful psychological effect
on
on
on everybody in america
but i think there are many people in the
united states liberal intellectuals who
are
really i think so
affected emotionally by what happened
on 9 11
that
i think it began to distort their
thinking i know they wouldn't like me
saying this um let's start their
thinking about what was happening in the
world and about america's role in the
world and and they were sort of becoming
hysterical
uh
over terrorism
and again yes there's a reality of
terrorism but there's a difference
between
dealing with terrorism in an intelligent
and and real way and becoming hysterical
over terrorism in the way that actually
liberals in the 1950s
those of you who know some of the
history of
of in of the united states in the 1950s
during the cold war period during what
is called the mccarthy period you might
remember that there were
not just mccarthy people
but liberal people
democrats
uh
who
uh reacted hysterically to to what they
considered the communist threat i mean
to the point where hubert humphrey who
is sort of a quintessential american
political liberal hubert humphrey
suggested
the notion of
internment camps
for dangerous people
in the united states uh in times of
crisis
uh
and uh and i think we're seeing you know
something of the same phenomenon because
i was reading
in in the liberal magazine the american
prospect with the editors in their
recent issue
they uh
you know they
their premise is that
the greatest immediate threat to our
lives and liberties are islamic
terrorists with global reach
well
and therefore when facing a substantial
immediate and provable threat
the united states has both the right and
the obligation to strike preemptively
and if need be unilaterally against
terrorists or states that support them
uh
preemptively and if need be unilaterally
well that is the bush doctrine
and of course uh
they qualify this by saying
facing a substantial immediate approval
threat the problem is
that
those who decide whether a threat is in
fact
substantial immediate
provable people who decide that
will not be the liberal intellectuals
who formulated this but the people who
run the government of the united states
they will decide it just as bush decided
it when he decided to go to war in
afghanistan and when he decided to go to
war in iraq
and
so
this idea
these ideas of unilateralism and
preemption and
and uh
these these are these are not new the
whole history of
uh the united states in the world is a
history of expansion based on these and
and also and rationales given like the
rationales given today
when we go to war about spreading
liberty and democracy and and
civilization uh and you know we
declared war on mexico in in 1846 and
again for the purpose of uh sort of
teaching civilization to the mexicans
and then
we went into cuba in 1898 and uh to
bring liberty to the cubans and
uh
in fact there's you know there's always
a
or a lot of times a certain measure of
truth to these statements that is we did
expel
spanish domination from cuba we we
liberated the cubans
from spain but not from ourselves
because once spain was gone the united
states moved in corporations moved in
the american military moved in american
wrote rewrote the cuban constitution
uh
but the rationale was you know we are
bringing freedom to the cubans and then
of course going into the philippines and
and
bringing civilization as mckinley said
christianity will we will christianize
and civilize the filipinos
and
because we are we are we are different
uh we are better there was uh at the
time of the of the invasion of the
philippines the american secretary of
war elia roots said
uh sort of a
very
classical statement of of american
exceptionalism
he said
the american soldier is different
from all other soldiers of all other
countries since the world began
he is the advanced guard of liberty and
justice
of law and order and of peace and
happiness
the american soldier is different
because now right now
immediately now
and in the wake of abu ghraib in the
wake of all these revelations coming out
every day about torture
and
atrocities and so on
that's
doesn't sound right
but you might say well root could not
anticipate
abu grey but he didn't have to
anticipate because at the time he was
saying this the united states was
already committing atrocities and
massacres in the philippines
by these american soldiers who were
different from soldiers you know all
over the world
and
and our
the history
the history of american expansion
in the world is not a history
which
is taught very much
uh
in our schools or even in our colleges
and universities that is it's it's uh
um
we have something called diplomatic
history
that's a discipline discipline is
diplomatic history and that's what our
history is very often it's diplomatic
history and we diplomatically treat the
american
uh you know foreign policy in the world
because if if young people
in our schools
learned the history
of
united states expansion in the world
if they learn the history of the
massacres and invasions that accompanied
american expansion in the world
they could not possibly believe the
president of the united states when he
gets up
before the nation and says we're going
into this
uh
uh country to for liberty uh and
democracy this is operation enduring
freedom and so on
but that history is not there and and
this misuse of history is it continues
to be perpetuated
uh by our political leaders
and
not
really caught or criticized
by that
part of the american culture which is
supposed to check up on and criticize
what the government does that is the
press uh the media
and so you you you have bush uh
appearing as he did a couple of years
ago before the philippine national
assembly and saying uh to the philippine
national assembly uh
the uh
i don't know he said america
is proud of its part in the great story
of the filipino people together our
soldiers liberated the philippines from
colonial
rule well people in the philippine
national assembly sitting there
you wonder
must have taken a lot of self-restraint
to just sit there
and and listen to this liberated the
philippines
600 000 or so filipinos died in this
long war against the filipinos
uh and at the end of it when the united
states was triumphant it did not bring
liberty to the philippines it brought
decades and decades and decades of
military dictatorship to the philippines
but
i remember
um there was a point i don't know about
a year ago where
the mexican ambassador to the u.n
said something undiplomatic
about the united states and mexico
he said something about how the united
states
has been treating mexico as its backyard
he was immediately reprimanded by colin
powell
who said that he this man did not
understand the history of u.s
mexican
relations
and in fact
he was soon removed from his post
that's how much clout we have
he was removed from his post
as mexican ambassador
to the united nations
so
so yes without that history you might
you might actually believe bush when he
says in his recent inaugural address
that
it is how did he put it that is
the sort of the mission
uh of the united states
uh to spread liberty around the world as
he put it spreading liberty around the
world as he put it as the calling of our
time
and if you read the newspapers including
the so-called liberal press the new york
times the washington post right after
the
uh
bush's inaugural address
you saw a flurry of
praise
for
what bush had said that the people were
in the editorial rooms of these
newspapers were so eager to hear those
words about spreading liberty in the
world and as if everything else that has
been reported from iraq over the past
two years
is meaningless
in the light of these beautiful words
uttered by george bush
but
all i would have to do would be to just
with a very short memory remember that
a couple of days
before
bush's inaugural
uh
address
a couple of days before that there was a
photo
in
the new york times which some of you may
have seen was it showed a
an iraqi girl
crouching
bleeding
and according to the caption she was
screaming
because her parents
had just been shot to death
by
americans
firing on their car
and of course you know there's always
well we
claim the military will investigate
we there were warning shots how do you
distinguish a warning shot from a shot
but in any case
some
to me this was some
remarkable juxtaposition of
but also a testament to the to the loss
of memory even a memory that can last a
couple of days
to see this uh
eager acceptance of bush's words
about
liberty
and
this idea of
american exceptionalism
you were told i would speak for an hour
so
i'm taking advantage of every minute of
it
you see
because when i heard it i said no i'm
not going to speak for an hour
actually i'm going to speak for two
hours
but
what this idea of
a special american dispensation in the
world
what it leads to
is a an
abrogation of all sorts of
responsibilities
to
the human race to everybody else in the
world
and it means that the united states is
exempt
from these responsibilities
uh
well
when i told you about madeleine albright
declaring that we have a right if
necessary to be unilateral when she said
that henry kissinger said
this principle
of our right to take unilateral action
he said
should not be universalized
that's an
interesting
thought
it's a it's a good
principle for us
but no it shouldn't be universalized
no
and so there are all this there's a long
list of instances in which the united
states
has declared itself exempt from a sort
of international agreements and
international laws and uh the un charter
and the you know the convention on
biological weapons you know which
was actually signed some years ago but
which didn't have any teeth didn't have
any force and when it was proposed to
enforce the uh the
this convention on biological weapons a
few years ago the bush administration
said no no way
it wouldn't go along with that and and
you know and i think most of us know the
united states has not gone along with
the hundred or more nations that have
outlawed land mines
and just the other day i i
spoke to a
listen to actually
and spoke with presentation by a
surgeon an italian surgeon who for 15
years
has been
doing surgery on war victims in every
possible war zone of the world most of
the most of the people he operates on
which includes a lot of amputations are
children
and much of that comes from land
a hundred million of which are strewn
around the world but the united states
wants to be exempt from the notion that
we should outlaw land mines and of
course we continue you know we uh
things outlawed by you know the geneva
convention and
cluster bombs and napalm
and
and
so
well
so what's the answer
what's the answer to to this
uh
very dangerous notion
of
uh american exceptionalism of our right
to do as we will
in the world
well i guess you know the
i guess the answer is sort of
obvious and you know
that the answer is that uh
those of us in the united states and in
the world who don't accept this idea
must uh declare very forcibly and and
act
very
vigorously
against this idea
and insist that the
ethical norms
uh that most
decent people can agree on
should be observed
and
and that no country should be an
exception
to the
rules of morality in world affairs
and that
the children of the world should all be
seen as part of a family and that and
that
the children of iraq or the children of
china the children
of anywhere in the world
have the same right to life
as american children
i mean those are
very fundamental moral principles which
the if our government doesn't uphold
them we must uphold them
fortunately there there are people all
over the world who who want to uphold
those principles and who oppose it when
the united states does not and we saw
you know on february 15 uh 2003
uh on the eve of the of the invasion of
iraq we saw that
amazing moment when on one day 10 to 15
million people around the world
60 70 countries around the world
demonstrated
against that war
and we've
uh
so there are people all over the world
who who do not accept the idea of
american exceptionalism
when last week the state department
issued its report on human rights abuses
some of you may have seen that in the
newspapers state department issued this
report on on it does this every year it
lists countries which are guilty of
torture and other abuses of human rights
and
and so it lists
a bunch of countries a number of those
countries are countries which are allies
of the united states a number of those
are countries to which the united states
has sent
prisoners
and you know i think by now you know
that this notion of extraordinary
rendition
where
we're not going to torture these people
we'll send them to countries which will
torture them and so the state department
issues this list of countries which have
violated human rights
and then when the when the report came
out there were
responses from around the world
which said hey there's one country which
is missing from this list
yes what about the united states
and what
and uh
and the uh
the turkish the turkish newspaper said
there's not even a mention of the
incidents in abu ghraib
prison
uh no mention of guantanamo
a newspaper in sydney australia
pointed out that
you know the united states sends
suspects remember suspects are not
people who've been tried and found
guilty of anything just people who
suspected of doing something send
suspects to prisons in morocco egypt
libya uzbekistan
you know countries that the state
department says uses torture
and uh so
uh
people around the world yes and here in
the united states
and this is
uh
this is something that
we very often are deprived of we're not
only deprived of history we're very
often deprived of immediate history
because we're deprived of things that
happen in this country that people are
doing
that uh
we don't know about because this is a
big country and beca but that's that
would be an easy excuse that we're a big
country and that's why we don't know
about them no we don't know
about these things that are happening
around the country these uh protests
these
declarations of humanity we don't know
about them because they're not really
reported
uh
and
so you well you you know
if you go to the internet you might find
out
if you go to a rally you might get some
of this information if you travel around
the country you might learn that you
know
this coming weekend there will be
demonstrations in cities all over the
country is going to be a demonstration
in new orleans this could be a
demonstration
uh
in
fayetteville on north carolina there
and
there's a resistance movement in the
united states to this war and you see
only the
the
superficial
you might say recognition of this when
you read public opinion polls which show
that now about half the country does not
believe in the war and if half the
country does not believe in the war then
somewhere among that 50 percent there
must be many many people who are
actively opposing that war and those
people
are are in fact engaged in protests
all over the united states and what's
perhaps most significant is that in the
armed forces and in the families of the
armed forces
there is more and more
defection from this war the
iraqi veterans
against the war
formed
in kind of
reprise of what we had during vietnam
vietnam veterans against the war and we
have
military families speak out of the
families of soldiers
organizing and who now have thousands of
members
and gi's themselves gis in the field and
you read about instances of mutiny and
uh and gis who who say we we don't want
to who've been to iraq who are being
sent back who don't want to go back
uh and some of them go to canada and
some of them get court-martialed and
this is important because i think of
i think of
what einstein said when
at the end of after world war one
horrified
by that war and by the idea of war
itself and by the knowledge that now
modern warfare
uh would be indiscriminate and massive
and einstein said
wars will stop
when men refuse to fight
and so the
yeah the refusal to fight and refusal of
families to let their kids fight and the
insistence of of the parents of high
school kids that they will not
let
recruiters come into the high schools
and approach their kids all of these
things uh
these things are
consistent with what einstein thought
was ultimately the way that wars would
stop
so i leave you with
the idea that uh
we're not alone and that there are
people all over the world and people in
this country
who uh do not accept the idea of a
special dispensation to do whatever we
want in the world and who will insist on
on a human equality of people everywhere
and i'm
i think of
william lloyd garrison
the
abolitionist i think of what was on the
masthead of his
of his anti-slavery newspaper
the liberator on his masthead with the
words
my
country is the world my country
men are mankind
a good thing to remember thank you
okay
all right hi professor oh
um
my question was uh do the people in our
government do they do they believe
they're on rhetoric
because i feel it must take an extreme
suspension of belief to uh
you know believe a lot of this rhetoric
of democracy and
you know american freedom being spread
everywhere
and you know
or do they act knowingly
and if they act blindly is it because of
the structure of our educational systems
and our government
or
do they simply act into knowledge
uh disbelief
this will be just
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
did you all hear the question
okay
do the people in government who do what
they do do they believe
in what they do or are they
brainwashed
by
themselves
or that is did yeah but essentially
that's a tough
it's a tough question
and
i don't think i have an answer to this i
don't know if anybody has an answer this
because i think there's
i think the answer varies from person to
person i think there are people who
uh
who understand what they're doing and
don't care
you know they they know what they want
and they're going to get it and they
don't care and they're willing to lie
but the lies
are acceptable because it's going to
achieve the results that they want these
are these people are cynical people
they know what they're doing and there
are other people i think who persuade
themselves
and
i mean the human
mind has
an infinite capacity for
self-deception
and it's and therefore there are there
are people i'm sure there are people in
government who who really believe in
what they're doing who actually believe
that they're
advancing the cause of liberty and
democracy in the world by what they're
doing but as i say i don't think there's
any one answer for
for this uh
great conglomeration of decision makers
i wanted to ask
which kind of
my name is tomer gotef i'm one of the
humphrey fellows i'm from israel
and i wanted to ask which kind of
institutions in american society
do you think needs to implement these
moral norms because i was looking at the
united states policy in the last two
years
the detainees at guatana and about the
judiciary and i was
seeing that the judiciary was more
interested in gay marriage than in
detainees
rights and i was asking myself which
kind of institutes will handle these
kind of moral issues that you're
speaking about you say what kind of
institution institution
uh
i think we've
especially in in countries that
have
uh institutions
that
seem democratic and
and that you know on the surface
will guarantee our liberties i think
that is a country like the united states
we tend to overvalue institutions and
very often we think that if
a situation is bad we can correct it by
setting up another institution
or by amending the constitution i've
heard i can't tell you how many times
people have approached me and said
i have the following amendments to the
constitution
and don't you think that if we adopted
these amendments that everything no
institutions
are all
malleable subject to interpretation well
we can see that with the constitution we
can see that with even the supreme court
which claims to be a strict interpreter
of whatever the constitution says
and
no all these all these institutions
depend on who has the power
and the and laws are violated with
impunity by the government it doesn't
matter what laws you pass and you can
pass a law limiting the powers of the
fbi it won't matter
because the fbi
doesn't have to obey the law
because
if the fbi violates the law who will
go after it
the fbi
i mean the
we have a long history of government
violation of law
and
and so
the answer
doesn't lie in institutions or
even in laws now it helps to have some
laws rather than other laws but but
the
uh those aren't critical i mean we had
we changed the constitution at the end
of the civil war to give black people
uh well freedom from slavery uh
presumably equal rights with the 14th
amendment the right to vote for the 15th
amendment and so there we had
institutionalized racial equality it
didn't matter
because the 13th third the 14th and 15th
and to us even to a certain extent the
13th because blacks were really put back
into semi-slavery by their lack of
resources but the 14th and 15th
amendments was simply
uh unenforced
not only were they unenforced but the
14th amendment presumably passed to uh
you know assure equality for
black people 14th amendment became a
tool for corporations
to protect corporations against a
governmental regulation and so the
laws uh institutions
are not critical as i say it's sure it's
better to if you can
if you can set up better institutions if
you put better laws in
fine but that is never enough
the it takes
uh
citizen action
i mean when we've had
changes important social changes take
place in this country it hasn't come as
a result of changes in institutions
certainly not changes in
who is elected uh
and no it's come through the growth of
social movements and that's that was
true of winning a
degree of freedom for
ex-slaves and as true of winning
rights of workers
and true and well in recent years
whatever rights have been
won by
women or by disabled people or
by black people they have not come
simply through the
change in institutions although that may
accompany
the social movements and that make come
out of the social movements but
basically it's citizen action and
organization and willing to
take risks
on behalf of
important values those have been crucial
my name is ian finlayson
i would think it would be exceptional to
think that this problem was a uniquely
american problem and that over the
course of history we've had numerous
societies assume that they were
exceptional
the romans the british the japanese
uh at different points in time so as a
historian can you give us any examples
where
societies have successfully climbed down
from this
uh
from generating a myth about themselves
to actually uh
assuming that they're
equal with other people
is there any success stories
historical examples of where
nations have
sort of divested themselves of this
exceptionalism and accepted the idea of
equality with other people
only
of this when
they were forced to
that is the british empire
was dismantled but not
you know not
out of the
you know sheer generosity
but you know it was forced to dismantle
uh
and
and
no i don't know of any government which
has claimed a
exceptional position for itself
which has given up that
indeference to human rights
but
but governments and empires in the past
have fallen and have been forced to
uh
retrench
as you know
the belgians and africa and
the british and the french and asian but
only
when compelled to
by resistance
when speaking about exceptionalism you
were talking about a
outside threat helping to justify
a lot of
us
aggression
and
taking on
imperial elections i was wondering prior
to the justification of communism what
was u.s justification for expansion
and
what was it what was it prevailing as as
part of a reflection of the time that we
all lived through what was the
prevailing thought between
the fall of communism
and
the uh the the prevailing idea of
terrorism though
well
so
two two
questions i guess
and uh but
i mean what did we do before
was our justification before
communism i was just well there's all
your
different justifications
uh you know over
you know that those several centuries
and
in the
in the case of
for instance
our wars against the indians in our
expansion there very often the
justification
was
uh
that
we were civilizing them they were savage
group and
and uh we we were
uh and if we were civilizing them and
when we conquered them we tried to you
know take the young people and put them
into special schools to teach them
civilization and so on so as
civilizing other people who were
backward uh that was there was a certain
amount amount of justification for that
in the mexican war certainly in in the
philippine war
and as i pointed out in cuba the
justification was liberating the cubans
in the case of our forays into
central america of which there were you
know many many
marine forays into uh central america uh
in the early part of the 20th century
you know culminating in you might say
the long occupation of haiti and the
long occupation of the dominican
republic the argument the justification
was that there was disorder
and
we were
bringing order
to these countries
and you know in the case of for instance
of theodore roosevelt to develop
something called the roosevelt corollary
the justification was
corollary to the monroe doctrine
justification was well he's uh
they're they're unstable
they're
not
able to take care of their own finances
which means they they really can't take
care of their obligations to the united
states we don't like that
so they're they're varying expanding
reasons given for
for
all all of these
foreign policy actions
before
communism became a kind of
easy monolithic
uh
kind of
excuse
uh
and you're asking about what went on
between
between the fall of the soviet union and
and
the war on terrorism well i guess
you see an example in
in
the war on
panama
uh right and uh
or
uh the first gulf war
the war on panama takes place just at
the point where the soviet union's is
falling apart the justification of the
war on panama is
well
noriega
a bad man
you know
he no longer likes us he did at one time
he worked for us
doesn't want to work for us anymore and
and furthermore he's involved in a drug
trade and we want to get him and we want
to do something about the drug trade
well
yeah if you know what's happening with
the drug trade today
uh you'll be dubious about that as um
by the way there's a intro
if you want to read something more
interesting than
the kinds of things i tell you
about history and about panama read
john le carre's
novel the taylor of panama
and in john le carre's novel the taylor
of panama he has a small section which
he deals with the american invasion of
panama and the mayhem that we created
in panama but then of course the first
gulf war
took place uh between the you know
collapse of the soviet union and
and the
and the war on terrorism what was the
reason
there well the reason there
the the justification given for that was
that
um
iraq had invaded and
kuwait which is
certainly true
and certainly
not justifiable
but there's a there's an interesting
leap that takes place
in
thinking about
uh
war
it's a leap from a just cause to a just
war
there's the
uh
a cause may be just and that is sort of
keeping kuwait out of saddam hussein's
hands is a just cause
but then
you're making a jump if you immediately
rush from that to the idea therefore war
is required
just as in korea we it was a just it was
unjust for north korea to move into
south korea but
so there was a just cause there but
that leaves open the question of whether
then the proper response the human
response the best
response
to
uh that was to go to war and therefore
would be a just war well
not quite we know now we've three years
of war in korea
two to three million
people
dead in korea at the end of it we were
back where we were when the war started
back to north korea dictatorship south
korea dictatorship
uh
to be
so it was a just cause the question is
should we have gone to war
did we go to war
and this this motivation is important
and therefore you know
it is important to to ask
whether motivations
that are expressed
are honest ones
and i think it's worth thinking about
this question
did george bush senior
go to war against iraq in 1991
because he was heartbroken over the
invasion of kuwait
that's hard to believe
it's you know it's uh
there's been other invasions we've
another occupations
we don't go to war over every invasion
every occupation is it possible that
there's something about iraq and its oil
reserves and the middle east that
prompted
again the
the real taking over of kuwait but made
that a very convenient excuse
to
move into
iraq and then to establish bases there
when and the
the uh
the bases that we established in saudi
arabia came directly out of out of that
war
last question
oh
my name is james
um
there's an a current of american
exceptionalism if i'm not mistaken
that has to do with trying to explain
why there hasn't been a strong social
democracy in america
like there has been
in
some if not many european countries
and i think
probably the most the best known
exponent of this
is probably if and correct me if i'm
mistaken seymour martin lipset the
canadian political scientist i think is
one of the best known
to put forward this attempt to explain
american exceptionalism i.e the absence
of
a strong social democracy
or even
a stronger socialist movement um
do you
what's your
take on this current
of what
is sometimes referred to as american
exceptionalism and but more importantly
what's your take on the whole idea of
trying to come to terms with
quote unquote why there hasn't been
a stronger movement for social democracy
realized social democracy in in the
united states and and parenthetically
how much would you say
the incredible diversity in this country
is part of the challenge that anybody
interested in in that programmatically
has to come to terms with
well
james
[Laughter]
you know that's a big question and i
don't deal with big questions
i did little ones
i like little questions
uh
and
well you mentioned diversity and you
know
this is an issue which american
historians and political scientists and
you know some have grappled with for a
very long time so here are my mit on
this day and i'm going to give the
definitive final i'm going to i'm after
all all these people have worked on this
i am going to tell you what the real
truth is
yes of course
you mentioned
it's uh
you can give a number of reasons why we
haven't had a very powerful radical left
movement in the united states you know
and you can find yes diversity the size
of the country the
the
all the conflicts between immigrants and
native born the use the
pitting of people against one another
black against white
uh
the reformism of the united states the
the doling out of little goodies to the
middle class to create a large enough
middle class to act as a buffer between
the very rich and and the very poor
there and there are a number of reasons
for
uh i think for
uh the fact that it has been a powerful
movement in the united states but i
would add one more thing
i think there's a tendency on the part
of a lot of people
i would never accuse you of this james
but
there are people who
i think make too great a distinction
between the united states
that is who see too much exceptionalism
there too great distinction between the
united states and other
uh
post-in industrial
countries you know as if well these
countries have great social movements
england france italy and
and but the united states lags behind i
i don't i reject the idea of that sharp
a distinction
between these countries in europe
granted that you know the show there's a
big powerful trade union movement in
france and there isn't a powerful trade
union movement here but we have had
we have had important social movements
in this country uh
from time to time and we'll probably
have one again especially if things
continue the way they are
and uh
and
i think it's too easy to denigrate the
uh
the amount of social protest and social
organization and resistance that there
has been in this country uh
throughout our history uh
and i mean at the beginning of the 20th
century we had a very powerful socialist
movement in this country we've had
radical labor unions at the beginning of
the 20th century and then again in the
30s with the cio
and we and
you know
the movements the great movements of the
60s uh very important social movements
uh you might say more uh a certain way
more
uh
which had no no counterpart
uh really in europe except you know
france 68 and so on but i guess what i'm
saying is i don't think we're as
exceptional
as a lot of people make us out to be
in lagging behind in the development
of social movements and social
consciousness we have a long way to go
that's the last question
okay
you